Earth is a solar powered planet.
At the bottom of the food chain, plants use
photosynthesis to convert sunlight into
chemical energy.
Food for the rest of us.
I like eating both grass and wheat, and I
also fancy the odd hamburger from a cow that
has eaten that grass.
This whole ecosystem is powered by sunshine.
But recent studies have shed new light on how
life developed under our sun.
Specifically the role of ultraviolet light.
Uv radiation is useful for breaking molecules
up and triggering reactions.
Maybe that played a role in the origin of
life.
It breaks down simple organic molecules, and
then they can rebuild themselves into things
that are more complex.
If you do that over and over again,
eventually you somehow get life.
Scientists think life on Earth started around
4 billion years ago.
A time when Earth's atmosphere gave little
protection.
Uv radiation levels were 100 times higher.
Was essential for the development of life's
code DNA.
We know that life on Earth stores information
in DNA and then uses that information to
build proteins.
So we have the blueprints and the bricks.
The blueprints are the DNA and the bricks
are the proteins.
But we think that the first life on Earth, we
used a chemical which is much simpler.
This simpler chemical was RNA.
Dna is single stranded forefather.
Rna is almost like a two for one offer.
It does both of the fundamental things you
need for a cell in the same compound.
So it was simultaneously the bricks and the
blueprint.
Unlike other molecules, RNA is more resistant
to the high UV environment of early Earth,
allowing it to flourish.
Rna eventually evolved into DNA, and life
started.
To have life on the planet.
One important consideration is a certain
amount of light that's going to be needed,
and a certain type of light that's going to
be needed.
So if all stars emit some UV radiation, can
life start around any star?
When we think about looking for places that
are conducive for life, we want to find a
planet that might have enough UV radiation.
So the star is is bright enough or close
enough that it's providing enough energy to
the surface for life.
But we also don't want to have too much UV
radiation.
It seems you need just the right amounts of
UV.
The most common stars in the galaxy are red
dwarf stars.
If red dwarf stars can harbour life on
planets around them.
There's an awful lot of real estate like
that in our galaxy.
Red dwarf stars could be good for life's
chance of conquering the universe in a number
of ways.
One. They represent over three quarters of
all stars in the universe.
Two they live for over a thousand times
longer than sunlike stars.
And three, they seem to have rocky planets
around them much more often than sunlike
stars do.
Those are the pros.
But red dwarf stars also have cons.
For instance, they might not be bright
enough for life to begin.
Some of the red dwarf stars that we know emit
less ultraviolet light than the sun.
They don't give off much UV light at all.
Maybe on a planet around them there isn't
enough energy to get life started.
Red dwarf stars are also much more
temperamental.
They can go from being gentle and quiet to
having violent outbursts.
Stellar flares.
These types of stars have incredibly strong
flares.
That means they're shooting off a bunch of
energetic particles and radiation and light
that's baking the surfaces of those planets.
If the star is just bombarding the surface
with UV, then it will destroy all of those.
Those things necessary for life.
It will actually destroy the life itself.
These stellar flares could strip away a
planet's atmosphere, sterilizing the surface.
More research is needed.
But for now, the odds of life thriving
around dwarf stars are a toss up.
So far, the only thing we know is that there
is one kind of star that's definitely right
for life our sun.
We know of life in one place in the universe.
And that's that's here.
That's Earth.
Only 4% of stars in the universe are like our
sun.
So if life can only get started around these
rare medium sized stars, the chances are not
looking good. But life may have an ace up
its sleeve.
What if life can start on just one planet
and then spread?
What if life travels across the cosmos
looking for planets to conquer?
Earth is our only example of life emerging
anywhere in the universe.
But what if life on earth didn't start on
Earth at all?
There's one idea that life.
On earth actually didn't get going here, but
was delivered from space.
Scientists call this theory panspermia.
The idea of panspermia essentially talks
about the transferral of life throughout the
cosmos.
We know asteroids and comets carry organic
molecules, but could they carry life itself?
What if life starts on one planet?
Can it actually get itself to a nearby
planet?
Is it possible that meteorites could
actually transport living beings.
For life to travel around the cosmos?
First, it needs to take flight.
An asteroid is on a collision course with an
inhabited planet.
So what happens if there's a huge cataclysmic
collision on a planet?
Material is blasted off into space.
The impact might kill life on the surface of
that planet, but it's possible some bacteria
might escape hitching a ride on chunks of
the planet's surface.
A meteorite being ejected from a planet after
an asteroid impact.
I mean, that's not going to be an easy ride,
but it turns out it's not as bad as you
think.
Some bacteria are very, very hard to kill.
Some we even don't know how to kill.
Even the impact that actually threw that
rock into space for bacteria.
No problem. If those chunks of rock expelled
during asteroid collisions could actually
hold on to viable organisms, then it really
could change the way in which we think about
life spreading in the universe.
If the microbes can survive takeoff, then
they can start their journey to a new home.
The odds of life conquering the universe
seem to be getting better.
The important question now is how long could
that life those bacteria, those
microorganisms inside that rock, survive the
space environment?
Exposure to UV radiation could be fatal,
killing any life on the surface of an
asteroid. But experts think that microbial
passengers could still survive by hiding
underground.
It doesn't take much to shield a
microorganism from UV, just a little bit of
rock and you have enough protection to just
hold on throughout a journey to the next
body, to your next home.